j'ai indiqué que le préfet va étendre le
port du masque dans l'ensemble la
capitale
[Musique]
c'est totalement inutile inutile ce
n'est pas nécessaire quand on n'est pas
malade il ne faut pas considérer que le
port du masque serait l'alpha et l'oméga
de la protection des personnes c'est
faux c'est faux et masques qui ne sont
pas nécessaires pour tout le monde je
vois énormément de masques dans la rue
je vois énormément de matches des
professionnels qui n'ont aucune raison
d'être exposés à des malades des masques
sont mal porter des masques sont mal
utilisés il n'y a pas besoin d'un masque
dès lors qu'on respecte la distance de
protection vis-à-vis des autres ne vous
précipitez pas dans les pharmacies cela
ne sert à rien en france d'ailleurs on
dit que sa salade le port du masque en
population générale dans la rue ça ne
sert à rien il est fondamental que les
personnes malades
est ce que vous avez acheté des masques
pour vous et vos enfants
ah non pas du tout il n'y a aucune
indication acheter des masques
[Musique]